- In this video, we're gonna talk about
how to burn fat,
a very important topic,
but a big problem, simply because
pretty much all the
mainstream recommendations
for burning fat are completely outdated.
In fact, look at the statistics.
In America, only 2% of the population
ever is successful at burning fat
and achieving their weight-loss goals.
An average female spends 17 years dieting,
so what does that tell you?
They're operating off of
incorrect information.
What I'm gonna tell you is based on fact,
physiology books, how the body works.
There's two main fuel sources in the body.
You have fat, and you have stored sugar.
There is a third one called muscle,
but I'm not gonna get into that,
because you have to be very, very sick
for your body to start
using muscle protein
as a fuel source.
We're going to talk
about the two main ones,
which is fat and sugar.
In other words, your body can store sugar,
the name of that's called glycogen,
in your liver and your muscles,
and that can release in-between times
where you're not eating
or it can go up to the fat.
The way it works are fat-burning hormones,
based on what you eat and what you do,
trigger the fat to release certain enzymes
to dissolve that fat,
called lipase enzymes.
They're hormone-sensitive fat enzymes
that break things down into ketones.
Ketones are the byproduct
of fat metabolism,
and your body can run on
these very efficiently.
Way better, actually.
It's a better fuel source.
It's a cleaner fuel source.
Your body could run on this.
Even your brain could run on ketones.
Now, fat-making hormones
trigger the storage of sugar
and the conversion of the sugar into fat,
so that's how that works.
The great majority of people are only
burning sugar, which is glucose.
They're not burning fat.
What occurs is they will lose
some temporary water weight,
and they hit a plateau
thinking that's actual fat,
but they never actually burn fat.
I can prove that, 'cause I
have a machine that measures
how much fat someone burns,
and you can very easily see
they lose water weight
and then they plateau.
The great majority of people burn sugar.
They're not actually burning fat.
In this next section,
I'm gonna tell you about
the single control factor,
what determines whether you're burning fat
or whether you're burning sugar.
So, here it is, the number one controller
of whether you burn actual fat
or whether you're burning sugar
is this one hormone called insulin.
Insulin, even in small amounts,
has the strength and the domination
to prevent you from tapping
into your fat reserve.
So, here's a little graph
on how much insulin,
or let's just say, when
I talk about insulin,
I'm gonna talk about sugar,
because sugar triggers insulin.
I could easily say the number one control
of whether you burn fat
is sugar or hidden sugars,
but I'm just gonna call
insulin sugar right now.
If that sugar is high, let's
say it's high sugar right here,
a high insulin,
you're not gonna be able to burn fat.
Your body is running on sugar.
So, let's say you eat moderately
and you have, let's say,
half of the amount of sugar,
because someone said,
"Everything in moderation."
It still won't work, because
insulin has to be zero
or sugar has to be zero
to tap into ketones,
which is the byproduct of fat
burning, which is ketosis.
In other words, it's not a
graph that's a gradual graph.
You have to make insulin,
or shall we say sugar,
zero before you can burn fat.
So now, what we're gonna talk about
is this thing called ketosis.
Ketosis is what we want to get into.
You may hear some negative
things about ketosis,
because it relates to diabetes,
but we're talking about doing
ketosis in a very healthy way.
Ketosis is the healthiest thing to do
for your blood sugars,
for your heart,
for your brain,
and other conditions like
polycystic ovarian syndrome.
Really, really important, because
think about that condition
the person is usually
always insulin resistant.
If they go on this, they
see great improvements.
So, we want to get the person in ketosis.
To get in ketosis usually
does not happen overnight.
It's easy to tap into the sugar reserve,
because all you have to do is eat sugar,
but to get into ketosis,
it can sometimes take
way more than two days.
It could take a week to
two weeks up to a month
and maybe, in some situations,
five or even six weeks
before you're really
hardcore into fat burning.
Now, why is that?
Because you've been living
on sugar your whole life,
and your system is so inefficient
and so used to burning
sugar to convert that over.
It's called a keto adaptation,
so you're adapting to burning fat.
It just takes a little bit longer.
Don't worry about it,
because you can see ketones in your urine
within a few days, but the point is
you want to stick with it a little longer.
I think what discourages a lot of people
is they think they're gonna
burn fat in a day or two,
and they get discouraged and they stop.
When, in fact, to adapt
your body into fat burning,
it could take up to a
month to possibly six weeks
in very extreme cases.
I'm telling you that because
it might happen in a week
or maybe a little longer than a week,
but just hang in there and stick with it,
because it will happen.
Your body will be burning fat,
and a lot of problems
will actually go away.
Now, let's talk about what
foods that you have to eat
to get into ketosis.
So, here's what you need to eat.
Number one, you want to
keep your carbohydrates
within 5 to 10% of the entire amount of
calories that you eat in a given day.
Now, the type of carbohydrates
we're gonna recommend
are vegetable in nature.
So, why vegetable?
Even though they have a
small amount of carbohydrate,
they have a lot of vitamins and minerals
that you're not gonna
get with protein or fat,
so we do want the vegetable
carbohydrates here
in a good amount.
The net sugars from that is gonna be
very, very, very low, if anything at all.
25% of your diet should
come in the form of protein.
This thing that I'm telling
you is not the Atkins diet.
Atkins is a lot of protein.
Our body is not made
out of a carbohydrate.
Some of our body is protein,
but a lot of our body is made out of fat,
and that's the third one right here.
65 to 80% of your calories
should be in the form of fat.
Now, before you freak out, realize that
I'm actually have been in
ketosis for quite a while,
and I have a lot of clients
that also have been in ketosis,
and it's a very healthy thing to do,
because you feel so good.
Fat, it's gonna be in
the form of healthy fats.
It's not gonna be actually
deep-fried anything.
So, we want the carbohydrates vegetable.
We want the protein.
That would kind of come
out to about, I'd say,
four to five, maybe six ounces
of protein with each meal.
See, most protein comes with fat,
so a lot of your protein source
actually comes from fat, as well,
But you do not want to
consume the lean proteins,
and that is because
you need that fat
to get your body into ketosis.
Eskimos consume blubber,
and they actually are
in a state of ketosis.
A lot of them actually have
zero heart problems at all.
If you're concerned about
increasing your cholesterol,
realize this.
Your body makes 2,000
milligrams of cholesterol
every single day.
Why would your body make
that much cholesterol
if it didn't need it?
When you consume more cholesterol or fat,
your body just makes less.
That's how it works.
You need this cholesterol to build
the surrounding around all your cells.
You need it as raw material
to build up your hormones,
especially your stress hormones.
You need it for the lens of
the eye and even the brain.
A lot of cholesterol is in our brain
to help the nerve connectivity.
Your body adapts to that,
so we need a lot of it.
I mean, like one egg
would be 300 milligrams,
so you'd have to have, like, 40 eggs
to equal what your body
makes every single day.
But it adapts, so you eat
less, your body makes more.
You eat more, your body makes less.
Now, 65 to 80% of your body
should be in the form of fat.
That is the formula to get
someone in fat burning.
One time, in high school,
I was a wrestler and I
tried to gain weight.
So, what I did was I
decided, well, of course,
if I want to gain weight,
I have to eat fatty foods.
I started losing weight
the more fat that I ate,
and that kind of confused me until later,
when I got into the physiology of it,
and I found out that consuming
fat is neutral with insulin.
Eating fat does not trigger insulin.
Insulin is the key
thing that must be zero,
because once you get your body
into fat burning by doing this,
all it's gonna take is
a little bit of sugar
to totally throw you out of ketosis
once your body has adapt to it.
You'll feel much better with your energy,
with your cardiovascular,
with your endurance.
If you add exercise on
top of this, oh my gosh,
it's going to be huge.
A lot of professional athletes
are going into this, as well,
because they have a
lot better performance.
A lot of credible medical doctors
even recommend this, as well.
It's a new thing.
You know it's true because
it's the exact opposite
of what mainstream is telling you to do.
They're saying have 60%
of your diet carbohydrates
and have only 5 to 10%
fat and protein the same.
You know it's correct.
If you just do the opposite
of what everyone tells you to do,
you'll come out ahead.
Now, if you want to know the specifics
of what exact types of
fats that you should have
and what combinations and some
ideas of maybe some snacks,
click the link below.
You can download
a page of what to eat
and how to do this correctly.
All right?
So, I hope you enjoy this,
and I will see you in the next video.